[Musique]
et si je vous disais qu'au japon les
médecins prescrivent des bains de forêt
ont prescrit une cure forestière comme
un remède contre la fatigue le stress la
dépression
comment en est on arrivé là au 21ème
siècle
c'est comme si nous étions coupés de la
nature comme si nous n'en faisions plus
partie pourtant la nature est partout
autour de nous nous la côtoyons de
manière plus ou moins directe que nous
habitions à la campagne ou à la ville
elle est présente dans ce que nous
mangeons dans l'air que nous respirons
dans l'eau que nous buvons est que nous
le voulions ou non nous sommes
étroitement interconnectés je vous parle
ici en tant que formatrice en éducation
à l'environnement et au développement
durable
j'ai l'impression que certaines
connexions ne se font plus ou se font
mal vous rendez vous compte on doit
prescrire des bains de forêt alors
comment faire pour développer notre
conscience environnementale
comment faire pour recréer des liens au
sein de l'écosystème
vous avez tous probablement lu des
livres regarder des conférences
peut-être écouté des tedx sur le sujet
et si je vous disais que le plus
puissant c'est l'expérience c'est vivre
l'expérience de son environnement se
connecter à ses cinq sens accueillir ses
émotions
c'est ce qu'il ya de plus fort et de
plus puissant pour développer sa
conscience environnementale
la chercheuse dominique cottereau parle
déco formation l'écho formation c'est là
où se tissent les liens des hommes au
monde entre soi et l'environnement
fourmies une multitude d'interactions
dont nous n'avons pas toujours
conscience et qui nous modèle tout
autant quel modèle l'environnement le
dehors et le dedans de lettres
communique sans fin le simple fait
d'être dehors nous fait grandir et nous
transformant en quelque sorte nos sens
sont des outils à fabriquer du sens
alors je voudrais vous proposer une
petite expérience pour essayer de
ressentir ce que c'est je vous propose
de fermer les yeux et de vous connecter
à un souvenir marquant que vous avez
vécu dans la nature et qui vous a fait
vibrer essayez de repenser au contexte
aux odeurs peut-être qu'il y avait à ce
moment là aux personnes qui étaient avec
vous peut-être au bruit particulier
essayer de vous connecter à se souvenir
alors ce souvenir est peut-être lié à
une émotion intense provoquée par le
lieu il est peut-être lié à un moment
partagé avec quelqu'un ou il est
peut-être marquant parce que vous avez
acquis à ce moment là un savoir vous
pouvez ouvrir les yeux
ce qu'on observe souvent et peut-être
que vous l'avez ressenti là c'est que
les souvenirs les plus marquants sont
liées à un moment à une émotion intense
provoquée par le lieu où à un moment
partagé et que vous avez été touchés
dans le coeur et dans le corps et on est
plus rarement touchées dans notre
cerveau par l'acquisition d'un savoir
l'écho formation considère que les que
le corps et le médiateur premier de nos
rapports au monde et que c'est avant
tout par le corps que nous faisons que
nous tissons pardon des liens avec notre
environnement
alors comment faire l'expérience de
notre environnement
ça paraît évident et ben pourtant c'est
pas si simple
et je voudrais vous proposer quatre
exemples pour illustrer le premier
exemple concerne les enfants en classe à
l'école ils sont de moins en moins en
contact avec la nature
on leur apprend ce que c'est qu'une
forêt avec des malles pédagogiques et
des vidéos en salles de classe dans les
cours de récréation on coupe les arbres
c'est dangereux quand il ya du vent
et puis les racines gondole asphalte on
privilégie les connaissances sur le vécu
ce qui est beaucoup moins risqué
pourtant c'est ce qui se joue dehors qui
va aller faire grandir les transformer
et peut-être ancré en eux
ces connexions si indispensable pour
leur équilibre futur imaginé une classe
de découverte et d enfants des cités qui
courent dans les grands en herbe au
printemps et qui plonge dedans comme
dans une piscine imaginez se déchausser
en montagne et marcher pieds nus dans
l'herbe
seydoux ça chatouille
c'est agréable il ya du plaisir
on sent vivant et certains enfants nous
disent que c'est la première fois
imaginez pêcher à la mare des petites
bêtes et regarder leurs drôles de têtes
à la loupe binoculaire ou encore
pique-niqué dans le cratère d'un volcan
dans mon deuxième exemple je voudrais
vous emmener dans un petit bois en
franche comté lors de rencontres entre
professionnels
au début nous étions plus préoccupés par
nos conversations entre collègues que
par ce petit bois qui nous paraissait
bien banal et puis l'animateur nous
demande le silence et de nous concentrer
sur le lieu est sur nous mêmes et puis
ils nous demandent de déambuler en file
indienne et là on commence à voir les
choses autrement
ces petits bois nous paraît déjà plus
singulier en contrebas coule un torrent
et le bruit de l'eau caresse nos
oreilles l'animateur se penche pour se
déchausser il y va quand même pas nous
emmener dans le torrent ça m'a l'air
très praticable et ben si ça rien dire
il s'engage dans le torrent et nous le
suivons ces froids
c'est inattendu les c'est extraordinaire
de l'autre côté il y à un coteaux
abrupts avec des arbres tombés de la
dernière tempête et notre animateur
commencé à s'engager à grimper sur le
coteau à enjamber les arbres ou
enchevêtrées pieds nus et nous le
suivons nous sommes ferrer ce petit bois
est resté à jamais ancré en moi ceux qui
se jouent les deux pieds dans le terrain
laisse des traces indélébiles
un troisième exemple je voudrais vous
parler des formations pour adultes
vous l'avez peut-être déjà vécu lorsque
le formateur vous propose un temps
dehors il y en a qui rit et que ce temps
est considéré comme un temps de détente
moins important que ce qu'on fait en
salle pourtant ce qu'ils jouent dehors
c'est pas une récréation c'est une
recréation je travaille sur cette
dimension avec des étudiants je leur
demande de se poser dix minutes que ce
soit par la nature ou en ville dans le
lieu de leur choix avec une grille
d'observation et je leur demande de se
connecter à ce qu'ils ressentent et à
leurs émotions d'essayer d'identifier
leurs émotions
eh bien vous me croirez si vous voulez
mais pour certains c'est un exercice
très difficile et pour d'autres c'est
une véritable épreuve
et si ces personnes étaient coupées
d'elle même au point qu'elle ne soit
plus capable d'observer ce qu'elles
ressentent et si notre monde allait si
vite que nous ne soyons plus en mesure
d'observer les choses simples qui nous
entoure comment réparer ces liens
altérée par nos modes de vie en 4e
exemple je voudrais vous parler des
animateurs professionnels
j'ai la joie d'accompagner des jeunes
animateurs qui démarre et j'aime bien
leur poser la question pourquoi faites
vous ce métier est souvent ils me disent
que c'est avant tout pour transmettre
des connaissances à leur public et en
creusant un peu il avoue qu'en fait
c'est avant tout pour transmettre leur
passion d'être dans la nature mais qu'il
n'avait pas osé le dire en premier lieu
c'est comme si dans notre société on sur
valoriser les connaissances comme si
c'était plus noble de transmettre des
connaissances que d'apprendre par
l'expérience
et puis ce n'est pas qu'une affaire de
professionnels réfléchissent et il y as
sans doute quelqu'un dans votre vie qui
vous a offert un moment partagé de
nature qu'ils avaient peut-être été à la
pêche avec votre papier ou et et
ramasser des champignons ou fait du
jardinage et ses expériences ont sans
doute contribué à vous faire grandir et
à développer votre conscience
environnementale
si nous prenons tous conscience de ce
pouvoir d'agir nous aurons fait un grand
pas car que deviendra notre écosystème
si les décideurs de demain n'ont pas
construit ce lien émotionnel à
l'environnement vous l'aurez compris
nous nous mettons des freins culturels
idéologique émotionnel imaginez trois
cercles concentriques avec l'individu au
centre
puis environnement social puis
l'environnement physique et l'individu
au centre pour bien fonctionner notre
écosystème a besoin de toutes les
interactions entre ces trois sphères
tout est imbriqué jean jacques rousseau
il avait déjà conceptualiser au siècle
des lumières dans en précisant que
l'éducation des personnes se faisait
s'articulait entre soit l'environnement
et les choses au japon ont prescrit des
bains de forêt pour les gens des villes
améliorer sa conscience la conscience
environnementale est un est vital pour
chacun de nous et nous avons tous le
pouvoir d'agir en prenant soin de notre
propre relation à l'environnement et
peut-être aurez-vous envie aussi de
partager la joie de semer de petites
graines et de devenir vous aussi des
éveilleurs de nature pour votre
entourage
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]